we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine to david p funny
voice mail today about jason let's take
a listen i bet you any day is not
accused of doing your lover as much
neither so give you a break from those
home lookbook and just remember y'all
have crushes on you that's really hate
on you so much it's no trick take it as
a compliment
yeah so far there has not what I think
maybe Rachel had a little bit of a hard
time hearing that the point being made
is we are not yet seeing the rush to
suggest Jason is my my boyfriend in the
way that often we saw with Lewis and I
don't know if that's a good thing a bad
thing I don't know that I would make a
value statement of it but it is
interesting if nothing else I'll take it
as compliment my my manliness is just
you know exuding yeah I'm exude hetero
yeah III Dex both yeah except for the
fact that the first comment about Jason
Rachel was that his name is gay and I
really I mean I of course we talked
about how ridiculous it is to even say
that a name is gay but just fixation I
don't get it
right I also think that that should be a
compliment the other way either way it's
a it's both a compliment and somebody
who is very bizarrely fixated on sexual
orientation
my advice to Jason is is just wait no it
would be a compliment if the opposite he
should be sad that they aren't saying
that he's your boyfriend right that's an
honor what if the implication is they
don't think Jason is enough good you
know to be my boy it's a big title to
fill well my head was held high and now
it's down low yeah anyway plenty more
time I am sure for that type of
speculation on the bonus show today we
will hear from Rachel whether or not she
ate shark and whale during her recent
trip to Iceland we will talk about drone
delivery and we will also talk about
what else a story involving hot water
boiling water being thrown onto a gay
couples face by a homophobe a truly
horrific story those stories and more on
the bonus show sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership